[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous parle de la caméra
des caméras des nouveaux iphone iphone
10 s max et iphone 10 16 qui hélas
important d'en parler parce que j'ai
fait le test il ya pas très longtemps en
vous présentant ses nouveaux iphone et
je me suis dit que là bas ça pourrait
être cool de vous tester la caméra pas
parce que c'est un point qui mérite
vraiment vraiment d'être vu à pas en
heures sup du nouveau je connais cette
couleur renmin syspro nouveau smartphone
de chaouchi est pas encore arrivé en
france qu'on peut faire venir à l'import
c'est une cabale version on en parle
d'ici quelques jours abonnez vous restez
connectés comme ça on va voir alors on a
d'autres trucs qui vont être testé très
très rapidement honoré 8x produits louis
colleu view de godo rico et le view de
police de huy cole a testé il ya pas
très longtemps le lieu de pro grâce à sa
complète la gamme
il y aura plein d'autres tests pas
d'autres nouveaux produits dont je vous
invite à faire une chose pour gagner
toute l'actu c'est à vous abonner et à
rester connectés
mais avant toute chose je vous parlais
d'une solution d'une solution qui
s'appelle la basse alors c'est une vidéo
qui est sponsor par la spa ce nom
proposé présenter leurs solutions au
final je prends ça très intéressant
parce que ça nous permet de gérer tous
vos mots de passe en os les mêmes
endroits sur le web
et ça franchement c'est cool parce que
je sais pas vous mais moi c'est une
vraie galère d'être sûr tous les sites
différents et d'avoir un mot de passe
différent pour chaque site parce que en
réalité pour sécuriser
il faut un mot de passe dédiée pour
chaque site alors si vous arrivez à vous
en souvenir tant mieux mais vu le nombre
de comptes que j'ai c'est à dire entre
les compte amazon contre lots le compte
gmail le compte youtube le compteur des
agents passent le comte netflix au lieu
d'un moment avoir un mot de passe dans
chaque site c'est très compliqué et
c'est là où une solution comme la spa
c'était vraiment intéressant parce que
elle elle va centraliser tous ces mots
de passe elle va vraiment sécurisé et
elle va en gros vous sortir une vraie
épine du pied et ça pour coup c'est
vraiment con alors je vous explique
comment ça marche
l'idée c'est que vous allez ajouter tous
les comptes que vous voulez par exemple
là je vais ajouter mon compte netflix je
le copie colle la nom d'utilisateur
le mot de passe et j'enregistre et la
netflix et ajouter directement ici
ensuite ce que je fais lorsque j'arrive
sur netflix je m'identifie et tout est
directement accessible grâce à la se
passait là par exemple je m'identifiais
sur netflix
j'ai enregistré mon compte netflix dans
l'espace je m'identifie ça me propose
mans comptant balas past je clique je
pose faith heidi hop ça déverrouille
gcim en compte
hop j'appuie je m'identifie et tout est
récupéré directement sur la spa cci
hyper sécurisé la spasad vraiment
centraliser tous vos comptes l'a par
exemple vous pouvez avoir des notes
sécurisé pour en enregistrer des
formulaires vous avez un site de partage
en challenge de sécurité que vous permet
de vraiment savoir où est-ce que vous en
être au niveau de notre passé ce que
vous avez vraiment quelque chose qui est
hyper sécurisé et d'avoir un score
global comme ça vous voyez vraiment
votre résultat voyez si vos mots de
passe sont sécurisés menons et ça c'est
quand même plutôt cool donc la solution
hyper sécurisé elle est pratique elle
est cool je ne peux que vous inviter à
la tester je vous ai mis les liens en
bas dans la description pour télécharger
les applis sur ios et sur android
commençons par le commencement ces
nouveaux iphone iphone 10 s iphone 10 s
max sont vraiment très bien en termes de
photos et de vidéos
voilà ça c'est fait maintenant je vais
vous expliquer et je vais détailler
pourquoi je vous dis tout de suite je
trouve excellent en termes de photos de
vidéos je les trouve pas aussi bon
photos que le p 20 pro de huawei est pas
non plus aussi bon que le galaxy note
l'ofs et galaxy s 9 plus je le mettrais
en gros en troisième position
néanmoins si vous aimez apple vous êtes
sous ios vous pouvez les acheter être
vraiment tranquille pendant la bonne
qualité en termes de photos vidéos sont
vraiment des super appareil sur ses
smartphones on a un ensemble de choses
qui font que ça marche vraiment bien
déjà vous avez la nouvelle puce à 12
bionic le sera l'adjoint de
l'intelligence artificielle un software
qui est complètement optimisé pour venir
vraiment traiter d'une élite est
vraiment excellente vos photos et vos
vidéos
vous êtes bien sûr du hd a partout ça
que vous détaille dans quelques instants
double module photo grand angle d
l'objectif 12 mégapixels pour les deux
marchent très bien sûr grand angle vous
avez une ouverture à f 1.8 donc prêt
lumineux tandis que sur le téléobjectif
vous avez une ouverture de f 2.4 point
extrêmement positif aussi de ces
capteurs l'arrière c'est la
stabilisation optique qui est vraiment
excellente et ça pour moi c'est un point
qui est vraiment très intéressant sur la
caméra de celle fille vous avez une
stricte mégapixels c'est la caméra trou
d'air qui marche bien
néanmoins je trouve que la qualité quand
même beaucoup moins bonne et surtout le
manque de stabilisation qui est pour moi
aussi un vrai défaut là dessus donc
caméra arrière topissime caméra à
l'avant qui marche bien mais ce n'est
pas non plus révolutionnaire c'est pas
vous faire le détail de la présentation
des modes d iphone parce que je pense
que vous les connaissez ce qui est
vraiment très intéressant là dessus
c'est effectivement la qualité de rendu
lorsque vous êtes sur des photos qui a
beaucoup de lumière le rendu est
vraiment géniale ici là typiquement je
suis au mondial de l'auto sur la partie
bécane le rendu juste dingue les détails
sont géniaux et c'est vraiment un
smartphone qui marche extrêmement bien
de ce point de vue là mais maintenant
qu'ils aussi vraiment excellent c'est
grâce aux hdr la gt par exemple à paris
sur les champs sur un petit after work
the way we work et regardez surtout là
ici c'est les lumières du soir la nuit
est en train d'arriver
vous avez vraiment le détail ici du ciel
si l'image est absolument pas cramé le
ciel et là on voit les nuages on voit la
lumière on a malgré tout la lumière de
la ville en bas tout est vraiment très
très très bien rendue et c'est vraiment
là dessus qu'on voit toute la puissance
de calcul de cette puce à 12 bionique
couplage du hdr avec ce doublé capteur
12 mégapixels ça marche extrêmement bien
c'est vraiment génial
autre point qui est tout bonnement
génial là dessus c'est sur le mode
portrait vous avez la possibilité de
régler la profondeur de champ dont vous
allez sur notre photo une fois vous avez
prises uniquement votre portrait est là
en bas vous allez pouvoir jouer sur la
profondeur de champ par quelque chose de
pas eu tout faux en arrière-plan
ensuite plus vous descendez et plus vous
est d'abord un flou en arrière-plan ça
c'est vraiment génial
ce qu'il faut comprendre l'action aux
tables de techno c'est que le rail
dungeon la puce à 12 bionique toute la
gamme bionique il ya eu la house bionic
est maintenant la douche bionique
elle va vraiment vous des pourrait
repérer tous les contours qui dessine le
personnage pour détacher et ensuite
vraiment pouvoir faire ce foudre
arrière-plan et alors là je le fais avec
la caméra arrière mais je peux faire
également avec la caméra avant parce
qu'autant avec la caméra arrière on peut
se dire bon on a un double capteur photo
c'est le téléobjectif qui vraiment ont
permettent de séparer les logiciels
derrière fait un peu sa popote à l'avant
vous avez uniquement une caméra de 16
mecs de cette méga pixels pardon donc
avec cette caméra de 5 mégapixels c'est
vraiment uniquement un traitement
logiciel
donc voyez là je suis complètement des
touré et j'ai tout le fond qui est floue
d'ailleurs vous ne voyez très très bien
là sur l'éclairage de seine ce qui est
très durable
moi c'est que comme j'ai l'esprit des
fois il un petit peu de mal à
reconnaître les contours et là les
contours ils sont vraiment bien pris
c'est vraiment impressionnant et c'est
ça qui est vraiment génial avec la
caméra cet iphone autant je trouve que
la qualité est moins bonne sur la caméra
avant je trouve vraiment excellentes sur
la caméra arrière
maintenant il ya un point que j'ai
approché cet iphone c'est son interface
au niveau de l'appareil photo le fait
qu'on ne puisse pas accéder ici aux
réglages et notamment au niveau de la
vidéo
voyez par exemple les six a voulu
marquer vous avez dû hd à 60 images par
seconde donc je suis en full hd sont
image par seconde par contre si
strictement impossible de venir modifier
l'âge est obligé de sortir d'aller dans
les réglages ici une fois que je suis
ici il faut que j'aille chercher
l'appareil photo l'appareil photo
l'appareil photo et où l'appareil photo
l'appareil photo les là je vais derniers
réglages de l'appareil photo et là je
peux changer le format des vidéos alors
1080p 60 images peut monter jusqu en 4k
directement ici à 60 images par seconde
mais le fait de devoir sortir de
l'application photos pour aller là où ça
vraiment très très très dommage voilà
pour cette vidéo test de la caméra des
nouveaux iphone de cette année iphone 10
s iphone 10 s max on testera d'ici
quelques temps les folles 10r
en attendant moi je vous dis d'un point
de vue général si vous voulez aller sur
cet iphone je ne trouve vraiment bien
extrêmement performant magnifique au
niveau de la réalité augmentée avec
l'application igo savard égale
franchement je m'éclate comme un vrai
gamin en termes de photos vidéos il est
excellent je trouve que le pépin pro et
le note 9 galaxy s2 plus sont au dessus
mais en tout cas je trouve vraiment
excellent et c'est du point de détail
savait effectivement sur une faible
luminosité sont deux choses comme ça
mais pour vous en utilisation
quotidienne un an vous soyez un strip
photographes mais sinon vous n'allez pas
forcément vraiment besoin by dans ce
point de détail là je trouve excellent
en termes de photos vidéos
petit bémol sur l'avant petit bémol sur
la partie software ça c'est pas bien
bien nouveau sinon vraiment un excellent
smartphone en termes de photos vidéos
vous invite blessure a marqué tout ce
que vous en pensez directement en bas en
commentaire comment vous trouvez
est ce que vous êtes satisfait oui non
est ce que vous le trouvez bien vous
marquez tout ça je vous embrasse vous
à très bientôt soyez sages prenez soin
de vous
[Musique]